since all this civil unrest started I
have wanted to know what my candy
companies think about racial relations
and oppression in America and finally
we've got the answer
gushers the little fruity candy where
when you bite into it that'll like the
juice kind of shoots out gushers you
know they've finally issued a statement
on black lives matter so gushers said
gushers wouldn't be gushers without the
black community in your voices we're
working with fruit by the foot i'm
creating space to amplify that I'm not
joking they actually sent this tweet out
we see you we stand by you and this was
this was followed by a long statement on
why black lives matter which was then
followed by the gushers logo at this
point dunkaroos silence is deafening on
this issue gushers statement on the race
riots and that is a statement that I
never thought that I would ever utter
gushers statement on the race riots
tells us a lot about institutional power
in the United States we'll get to all of
it I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
gushers dunkaroos I want to know what
capri-sun thinks about this I haven't
heard from them yet lots of institutions
weighing in on our on our deepest social
questions we will get to that because I
think this actually gets to the heart
not even just if the black lives matter
issue not even to the lockdown issue but
but really to deep political questions
in the u.s. first thought I want to get
to the question that I asked yesterday I
asked you what your favorite fictional
character of the last few months is the
choices were Batman the the abominable
snowman or the Yeti right Bigfoot and
the peaceful protesters I want to know
what which fictional character you like
my favorite answer actually was none of
the above it was President Joe Biden a
wonderful fictional character out there
is it very elusive harder to find even
than Bigfoot and the question I want to
know for you today after seeing our
Democratic leaders wearing those Kente
African scarves yesterday I was
half-expecting Schumer to show up in a
dashiki and a goofy hat I want to know
is it possible it's a little deep
conspiracy stuff is it possible that
Chuck and Nancy have actually been
bought off and they are at this point
working for the Trump campaign I don't
know I'm just putting it out there let
me know what you think in the comments
we hear a lot about institutional power
in the United States institutional
racism institutional oppression the left
keeps using that phrase I'm not sure
that it means what they think it means
we'll get to that in one second first I
got to thank our friends over at Legal
Zoom LegalZoom do not let legal
questions
hold you back Legal Zoom has been
dedicated to helping you with the right
solutions for more than 19 years I've
been using Legal Zoom just for my own
needs my own companies for far longer
than this show has existed I've been
using them for longer than the daily
wire has existed they're just so great
they guide you through the process even
me I'm not exactly great with paperwork
LegalZoom guides you through the process
every step of the way if you're looking
to protect your family with a will or
living trust or you're thinking about a
new way to start a business with a DBA
LLC nonprofit S corp which is what I did
legal tsums got you covered
easy to get started online if you need
guidance there network of attorneys can
provide advice to ensure that you make
the right choices these guys have been
in a long time they've got a great great
track record since legal zoo isn't a law
firm you won't need to leave your home
that's the best part as far as I'm
concerned and you won't get charged by
the hour also really important go to
legalzoom.com today to take care of some
important things that you need to get
done really as simple as a will or as
complicated as putting together a
company for special savings
be sure to use code Knowles at checkout
that's illegal zoom comm code Knowles
Legal Zoom where life meets legal you
hear this phrase all the time
institutional power there is
institutional racism and most
conservatives react to that by just
simply denying that that exists is there
institutional racism no fair enough but
let's think this through one level
further let's say that the left is right
let's say that there is institutional
racism and institutional oppression let
me ask you one question who controls the
institutions in the United States today
who controls all the mint virtually all
of the major institutions is it the
right or the left is it conservatives or
is it liberals any reasonable person
looking around at the media looking
around at the bureaucracy looking around
at the academy looking around and all of
them it would say it's the left the left
and last night on Sean Hannity's show I
think he hosted a debate that perfectly
exemplifies this this was a debate I
guess meant to he'll race relations in
America don't think it quite
accomplished that it was a debate
between the Marxist professor Cornel
West and the talk radio host Leo Terrell
just take a listen to a quick maybe
thirty Seconds a very telling thirty
seconds of the exchange you try to
conflate you try to conflate protesting
and police misconduct shame on you and
you're absolutely wrong you won't
address the issue you will feel too
British you
I'm telling you you're not my brother
you're not my brother you're my brother
do you oh my god you have lost control
you're a dinosaur dinosaur okay my next
question for the comments is how many IQ
points do you think you lost listening
to that exchange because I I don't know
man it might be up in the double digits
that was an exchange that if you didn't
see it you have you have Leo Tyrell
who's reacting to this crazy person
Cornel West and Cornel West is the
Marxist professor who is dressed up like
Karl Marx if you look at his outset if
you look at the way the guy looks he
looks in many ways like Karl Marx which
is not particularly surprising for those
of you who haven't followed Cornel
West's career he I'm not just using this
phrase loosely he is a Marxist professor
he is the head of the the African
American Studies department at Harvard
at least he was which by the way like
all critical Studies departments is a
fake academic discipline that is really
just pushing political ideology rather
than a traditional academic discipline
he very famously know while running the
FM department at Harvard he clashed with
then Harvard president Larry Summers
because Larry Summers suggested that
Cornel West should perhaps show up to
class rather than campaigning for
Democratic politicians it missed I think
weeks of class because he was
campaigning for Democrats
he said that Cornel West was
contributing to great inflation because
Cornel West was giving people easy A's
and then most outrageously instead of
publishing serious scholarly work well
while he was running the department at
this time he instead put out a hip-hop
CD seriously this is what a Harvard
professor was doing so Larry Summers
criticized this and then Larry Summers
was accused of racism because if you
tell people to actually publish
scholarly work while their professors at
top universities apparently that's
racist now regardless I think these two
guys who were debating on the show last
night I think they are a perfect example
not just of the individuals
here or the content of the debate you
couldn't say there was very much content
to that debate was just Cornell was
yelling crazy things at Leo their
representatives of institutional power
in the United States in the US right now
the Left owns the Academy they they're
Cornel West is a great example of
American academics right they own
corporate America because radical
left-wing messages under the guise of
racial healing or something but they are
at bottom politically radical leftist
messages Marxist in fact are coming out
from corporate America like gushers or
like fruit by the foot or whatever or by
every other company that you've gotten
emails from over the past few weeks the
left owns government even when
Republicans managed to get elected first
of all very often those people aren't
conservative they're more of the liberal
strain of Republicans but even when they
get elected if they try to fight back
and push too much then the the
bureaucracy what's called the deep state
or the administrative state pushes back
because the administrative state is by
its very character left-wing the Left
owns Hollywood that obviously the Left
owns the mainstream media virtually
every news organization that has
influence in the United States the Left
owns big tech which controls the flow of
information around the United States
virtually every institution is left-wing
with one exception talk radio and maybe
a few podcasts so Leo Terrell over there
a radio host is representative of the
one institution that the right kind of
has and so the debate actually makes
perfect sense
you've got the this academic sort of
ridiculous maybe pseudo academic at
least for much of his career versus this
radio host as evidence of the left and
the right who owns the institutions if
you've got a problem with institutional
racism allegedly
even before you deny it just go out
there and say okay if it's true maybe
you should blame yourselves leftists
because you run the institutions a
friend came up to me the other day Frank
came up talking about these messages of
BLM you know which which as we pointed
out on the show is not just about black
lives mattering far from it BLM on their
about page
says that they want to destroy the quote
Western proscribed nuclear family BLM
really radical stuff using words like
comrade you know a typical Marxist
language friend came up to me and said
with all of this BLM stuff going on the
media is so focused on ginning up racial
tension and ginning up racial division
it almost seems to me like they want to
make people racist and it isn't that so
crazy and I thought about it for a
moment and I thought that's exactly what
they want to do that's exactly what they
want to do why is that well it ties in a
little bit to some conversations we've
been having over the past few weeks
about liberalism itself that maybe
you've heard some conservative critiques
over the past few years critiques of
liberalism the broad liberal project
including classical liberalism including
libertarians we just this the whole idea
of liberalism if you had to boil it down
to a line or two is this idea of
emancipating yourself from this
oppressive past the past the tradition
our forefathers they were terrible and
bad and oppressive and we systematically
progressively are liberating ourselves
from that and there's a version on the
right that you see of that there's a
version on the Left that you see and so
intrinsic to liberalism is this idea
that you're constantly you have to be
liberating yourself from something
there's always got to be a bad guy
there's always got to be a boogeyman
oppressor that you're overcoming and the
problem for the left right now in
America is there just ain't that much
oppression they just ain't that much
they always talk about the white
supremacists the phantom white
supremacists that are constituting the
majority of Americans they're so evil
and terrible and that's why we've got to
stand up and courageously say black
lives matter even though that's a
statement that everybody agrees with
nobody disagrees with that statement but
we all have to pretend like there's a
huge number of people here who disagree
with that simple and obvious statement
and there just isn't so for instance
when the the allegedly peaceful protests
turned violent the mainstream media told
us well it turned violent because of the
white supremacists who showed up well
you know I'm looking at the footage I
don't see a lot of white supremacists
all the big threat here is the Ku Klux
Klan the
last image I solved the Ku Klux Klan was
an image from the Democratic governor of
Virginia's medical school yearbook
okay when he dressed up as a Klansmen
for Halloween or possibly in blackface
we still don't know which one he was in
but it was one of those the Ku Klux Klan
how many how many of them are there in
the country like four but the media has
to invent this phantom so that we can
then overcome it and extricate ourselves
from it you know we might be able to
celebrate in America that we have a
period of you know relative justice
equity prosperity Liberty you know
things are pretty good in this country
aren't they but that just doesn't work
and so the left invents the phantom they
invent this phantom of institutional
oppression without realizing the irony
that they control all of the
institutions and it's only going to get
worse you see it's not that I think some
squishes on the conservative side of
things they think that if we can just
prove to the left that no actually there
isn't that much oppression no actually
we aren't racist that then the left will
say okay good
that's not how it works the left is
going to double down they're gonna try
to gin up racial tension even more
they're gonna try to divide people even
more they're gonna try to invent even
more racists and bigots because they
need them to then overcome them they
need a villain and guess what buster no
matter how just a nice and wonderful and
and equitable you are and kind you've
got to be that villain if you oppose the
liberal left-wing agenda Merriam
Webster's dictionary just redefined the
term racism so racism according to
merriam-webster was quote a belief that
race is the primary determinant of human
traits and capacities and that racial
differences produce an inherent an
inherent superiority of a particular
race that's a pretty basic definition of
racism I think we can all accept that
none of us want to be racist okay so so
that's the problem is when you read the
definition of racism people say yeah
okay I reject that I'm not a racist I
don't think race is the primary
determinant of human beings worth I
don't think that therefore we should
have a politics based
Marylyn race okay I'm done with that now
the left actually does does push race to
the forefront when they're considering
their politics but what they have to do
to involve everybody in this issue of
racism is redefine it so now they're
redefining it as systemic oppression
meaning you can never not be a racist
because you're in the system and as long
as you're participating in the system
you're participating in racism you are
an oppressed oppressor this revision is
said to be coming in the coming months
though we don't have an exact date on it
that is the allegedly institutional
oppression now becoming the mainstream
definition some Democrats are pushing
back on this some reasonable Democrats
are pushing back and they are not being
treated very well by their own party
we'll get to that one second first
though I've got to thank our friends
over at ancestry DNA you might very well
be familiar with the major battles and
events of World War two but there are so
many more stories to uncover there for
instance the skill and bravery of the
Tuskegee Airmen and all African American
squad of fighter pilots incredible women
who trained to become pilots and
mechanics the japanese-american
battalion that became one of America's
most decorated units despite at that
time legal discrimination against
japanese-americans at home well in honor
of the 75th anniversary of the end of
the World War two ancestry has released
a US draft card collection from World
War two with over 36 million draft cards
completed by fighting age men in the
u.s. across the country during that time
whether they ended up serving or not you
know a lot of us have grandparents and
maybe for some of the younger viewers
great grandparents or parents you know
for some of the older older viewers who
served in World War two my grandfather
flew a b24 he was a navigator on a b24
airplane you can uncover all these kind
of personal details with the US draft
card collection shows details like home
address physical description war I love
these guys you know I've I've used
ancestry since before the daily wire
existed as well I still use them they're
just terrific
discover your untold stories and more
head over to my URL ancestry.com slash
Knowles to start discovering your story
today that is ancestry.com slash Knowles
kano wles
some Democrats are pushing back there is
a pro
from Georgia Democrat by the name of
Vernon Jones and Vernon Jones since he's
come out and said the I support a
support Trump he's gotten a lot of hate
that's come his way
he has seen a little glimpse of what
happens if you are a trump supporter in
any of the major institutions on campus
around the water cooler in the media in
Hollywood anywhere okay things don't go
very well for you usually in your career
so what Vernon Jones has suggested is
that since we have all these other
protections for all these other
characteristics of human beings since we
promote diversity in every other way
maybe we should protect people's
political viewpoints maybe we should
protect diversity of opinion diversity
of point of view so he tweeted a quote
political affiliation should be a
protected class right alongside race
gender and religion and my legislation
will do just that making any politically
motivated attack a hate crime wearing a
mag ahead should never endanger your
life and yet in many cases it does in
many cases you will be excluded from the
major institutions big tech right sensor
sensors conservatives way way
disproportionately this of course makes
sense and yet the left can't handle it
just on its face it's so common sense
right if you get a protection based on
your sexual preferences or your sexual
behavior shouldn't you get a protection
based on your political point of view
you know your your sexual behaviors are
just more kind of basic passions of your
body so if that's gonna be protected
shouldn't your higher intellect be
protected as well if you're gonna be
protected on the base of you know I
don't know your skin color or your sex
or your gender identity whatever
shouldn't you also be protected at that
higher level of the intellect things
you're actually thinking through and
choosing you already are in some ways
because of religion you are protected by
your religious beliefs so why not your
political beliefs as well and yet the
left is going to push back hard on this
the left is going to push back hard in
some ways I think because their
political beliefs very often are of a
religious nature right they've they've
got the they've got original sin in the
form of what they call white privilege
or systemic racism right they've got
Atonement in the form of taking a knee I
mean live that's quite visibly a
liturgical sign of kneeling down a
religious ritual they've got they've got
all sorts of religious characteristics
to them right they've got a utopia at
the end which is progressivism we're
progressing toward utopia and so what I
think the reason is that they don't want
to protect political affiliation here is
that they can't accept a challenge to
their dominant political religious
worldview it's just outrageous you can
we can tolerate anything in our tolerant
with a capital T liberal culture but you
can't tolerate intolerance of liberalism
right you can't tolerate a challenge to
the political system itself so I think
this guy Vernon Jones has a great idea
here and I think any sane society would
if they're gonna protect all those other
things should certainly protect
political points of view but something
tells me that they're not going to do it
virt what Vernon has done here has
gotten to the heart of that liberal
problem meanwhile talk about the
boogeyman talk about the villains that
we've had over the past few weeks the
cops right the cop with the cops are
being smeared by both parties mostly by
the Democrats but also by some squishes
as hopelessly racist bigoted unjust evil
murderers and we went through the
numbers the other day we said wait a
second the numbers don't hold up we're
being told there's this scourge of
racist cops hunting down unarmed black
men in this country even though unarmed
doesn't mean not dangerous let's just
use on armed for how many unarmed black
men are killed by the police every year
9,000 no 900 no 1909 is the answer nine
single digits every deaths a tragedy but
that is not evidence of a systemic
scourge and yet the cops are being
smeared so a head of a Police Union came
out yesterday addressed this issue and
said hey guys enough is enough I know in
your fantasy land you need a villain you
need the devil and that's currently
being played by us but it just ain't
reality 375 million interactions with
the public every year 375 million
interactions overwhelmingly positive
responses overwhelmingly positive
responses but I read in the papers all
week we all read in the papers that in
the black community mothers are worried
about their children getting home from
school without being killed by a cop
what world are we living in that doesn't
happen it doesn't not happen everybody's
trying to shame us the legislators the
press everybody's trying to shame us
into being embarrassed about our
profession well you know what this isn't
stained by someone in Minneapolis it's
still got a shine on it and so do theirs
so do this stop treating us like animals
and thugs and start treating us with
some respect great point when he says
this is not stained by someone in
Minneapolis he's pointed to his badge he
says the same thing is true of their
badges as well he says we're being
smeared as thugs
by the press by the legislators by
everybody according to the left-wing
fantasy the the evil cop it basically
according to the left-wing fantasy the
major institutions in the United States
are run by racist cops in the Ku Klux
Klan
I think that's that's the the
fantastical delusional worldview that
the left is pushing and yet what this
cop is saying is guys every institution
in this country is smearing us
undeservedly we are doing the sort of
systemic awful stuff 375 million
interactions every year between cops and
civilians how many go really wrong you
could count on one hand practically okay
that's the reality of the situation and
yet even the people smearing the cops
when you look at them even the most
left-wing hardened cynical politicians
are relying on the cops themselves they
just don't want you to be able to rely
on the cops when when reality hits when
the thugs and the criminals show up at
their doors
they want to be protected but you you
you're just fodder for their social
experiments and their ideologies of good
games we'll get into that in one second
first though I have got to thank our
friends over at rape speaking of safety
speaking of people that maybe you don't
want it your door knocking on your door
I'm not necessarily talking about
criminals I'm it's could be your
mother-in-law too and then you get a
knock on the door you get a ring you
take a look you say hmm time to be quiet
kids everyone hide out in the bedroom
let's not let anyone know that we're
here we're also home a lot more than
usual these days and it's hard to keep a
close eye on things even when you're
home right more deliveries mean more
boxes left unattended and as this
happened to some friends of mine more
packages that go missing a lot can
happen outside of your front doors but
we're not always free to check on things
in person that's why with ring you have
to keep your home safe no matter where
you are you could be in the bedroom you
could be at the office you could be on a
beach somewhere okay the video doorbells
let you answer the door and check in on
your home anytime without to our
security cameras you can check on every
part of your house smart lighting
brightens up blind spots makes sure that
you always come home to a brightly lit
house and the full home security system
gives you everything you need to protect
your family pets and property get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
right now when you go to ring calm slash
knowles
canada wles the welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell 3 and shine pro it's
all you need to start building custom
security for your home today ring.com
slash knowles that is ring comm slash
knowles so even the most ideological
leftists who are calling to abolish the
police and all that sort of thing one
thing I notice about them is they rely
on the police themselves LA City Council
President nori Martinez a Democrat
pushing to make huge cuts to the LAPD
now they're announcing could be a
hundred million three hundred fifty
million cut from the LAPD budget time
for me to get out of Dodge
decided that while she's defunding the
LAPD for everyone else she's gonna have
an LAPD detail stationed outside of her
private home not just recently not just
in June
not just in May going all the way back
to April private security paid for by
the taxpayers for
this woman who's then saying no one else
should be able to get that security
either that that sums it up right there
okay you do have this one group the cops
being totally maligned here for things
that they don't do for for lies and yet
the people who really control the
strings of power using them using them
not only for their own protection but
then using them as a prop to try to hide
the fact that they're the ones pulling
the strings okay and expect to see this
in cities around the country it's
becoming a real push now to defund the
police don't forget we play those clips
yesterday some Democrats are trying to
say oh when we say defund the police
robotis the police or dismantle the
police what we really mean is we want to
reform the police no we heard from those
major politicians yesterday do you mean
dismantle yes do you mean abolish yes
what does it look like in the future
a police free future what happens when
you call 911 you're not gonna call 911
cuz there's not gonna be any cops okay
that's what they're telling you and so
what's gonna happen ironically they're
talking about doing this in the name of
equality what's actually gonna happen is
that elites like the LA City Council
president are gonna get that private
police force for themselves and poor
people who live in bad communities with
lots of crime disproportionately ethnic
minorities are gonna be left to fend for
themselves huge disparity then in in
inequality which then by the way the
leftists who pushed all this can use and
exploit and pretend as evidence that
there's institutional oppression that
they are not controlling but they're the
ones who did it in the first place guess
what's happening since they're defunding
the police give you one hand what
happens when you tell the cops they
can't do anything you tie their hands
behind their backs
you defund them do you do you think
crime is gonna go down or do you think
crime is gonna go up I guess the
ideologue is tell us that if you get rid
of the cops crime is going to disappear
because somehow cops are responsible for
crime well the reality of the situation
is a little bit different so just for
the week of May 31st to June 6th right
most recent data we've got homicides in
LA increased not 2%
now 25 percent two hundred and fifty
percent victims being shot went up 56
percent that's just week over week just
in the 24 hours from yesterday Tuesday
to before that Monday just that 24 hour
period there were four shootings one of
those resulting in a homicide detectives
are trying to follow leads to ID and
arrest suspects but the detectives need
people's help because their hands have
been tied behind their backs that is
like a little preview a little
amuse-bouche type of appetizer of what's
going to happen around the country when
these when these cops are defunded the
reality of the situations can be very
different than the ideology and the left
running the institutions is going to use
that ironically as reason to give them
even more power now some Democratic
politicians it's not just that got
Vernon in Georgia other Democrats are
waking up and saying look what's
happening to our neighborhoods because
of your stupid ideas that happened in
Chicago - we got leaked audio of a very
hostile conversation between the an
alderman in Chicago and the mayor of
Chicago they they don't talk very
politely when they're when they think
that they're off the record we'll get to
that we'll get to Ryder's overtaking
Seattle we'll get to rioters in Richmond
pulling down a statue of Christopher
Columbus when Christopher Columbus have
to do with any of this I don't know they
just hate his guts we'll get to all of
that but first I've got to thank you
I've got to thank you for pushing my
total subscribers on YouTube past Drew
clavin's because that's what we're all
here for folks that's what this is
really all about so thank you very much
you know we put some bonus content over
on the YouTube channel I have an
exclusive interview with a pal of mine
Tim Gordon a Catholic author and
podcaster who was just fired from a
Catholic school because he opposed the
radical leftist aims of black lives
matter he dared to criticize them even a
Catholic school an allegedly
conservative institution now dominated
by the left also you know crazy this
year has been already it's just the
start of the year okay we've got still
five months before the presidential
election and the media are the ones
pushing this so if you don't think that
you can rely on the mainstream media to
get a reliable source of news which I'm
glad you're awake I'm glad you figured
that one out then head on over to the
Daily wire you know we've got some
exclusive in-depth content that is only
for members we've got a readers pass
that's already super chief it's three
bucks a month but now just for you we
are going to cut that down by two-thirds
for your first month you get it for just
99 cents you'll get push notifications
for breaking news and special content
access to our mobile app and the
community of daily wire members who are
actively commenting and discussing the
content with each other so head on over
to daily wire.com slash subscribe and
join today we'll be right back with a
whole lot more
even Chicago Alderman's okay these are
the guys who are kind of like the City
Council they're they're running the
government in Chicago notoriously left
weak city for a very long time even they
are beginning to realize that this is
not working out terribly well we have
leaked audio of an alderman speaking to
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot saying hey
over the past few weeks it's even
crazier than usual in Chicago our
neighborhoods are burning down and
you're not doing anything about it you
know what Lori Lightfoot had to say to
him no thanks don't care no I want an
answer I bet you comment it on everybody
I want an answer
it's not something you ignore this is a
question that I have if you think we
want to using using every we're ready
and we stood by and let the neighborhood
go up
there's nothing intelligent that I can
say to you and maybe you should come on
it what's going on it's stupidest thing
I've ever heard
I understand you want the pre I
understand that you think it man you
need to check your these guys it's I
really like this alderman too I mean
they they're they're a little more
polite when they know that the cameras
are on but they're really going at each
other because even this alderman says
wait a second this city which has been
run by Democrats for ever since the
prehistoric times is a trash heap of
crime right this city on a good day has
crazy crime in it right on a good day
more people are being shot and killed in
Chicago over a weekend then any number
of unarmed black men killed by police
and in a whole year right and yet you're
only focusing on this one issue and
you're letting our neighborhoods go up
in flames and the mayor says yeah I
don't care I don't care because it
actually serves their ends I know
there's this hope among conservatives
where we say gosh these leftist policies
are so bad that hopefully people will
just totally wake up and they'll realize
they're really bad policies and they'll
flip them
I don't think that's what's gonna happen
I don't think that's what has already
happened if that were true Chicago would
have woken up by now and elected
Republicans but they they aren't doing
that because the chaos and the violence
and the madness actually serves to
reinforce the left-wing control of the
institutions look what's happened in
Seattle Seattle is a left-wing city okay
and yet the rioters are getting really
really intense there Seattle is a hotbed
of anti feh you know the the anti
fascist allegedly another term for
communist or anarchist lunatics and
violent lunatics who were going out
terrorizing people the rioters in
Seattle broke into and took over City
Hall take a listen to them
so they've taken over there and they are
yelling this at the mayor liberal mayor
you're about to lose your job one thing
that these guys also chant a lot is this
is what democracy looks like you hear
that well this is what democracy looks
like a really dark view is gosh maybe
that is what democracy looks like if so
not a great recommendation of democracy
but I think the more reasonable view is
that's not what democracy looks like
democracy looks like showing up to vote
and being a responsible citizen and
taking care of yourself and trying to
live a virtuous life mobs taking over
and trying to occupy whole territories
and throw people out and tar and feather
them that's not democracy
that's a mob and that kind of unrest is
taken as evidence that the Democrats
should keep controlling things okay ant
Aoife has taken over whole parts of that
city there's a place now around Seattle
called the Chaz the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone there is an area where
these far-left protet protesters
peaceful protesters also known as
rioters and anarchists and communists
have taken over an area and they've
declared it their own zone okay and the
the the thing here is you people look at
that and I say wow this is so cushy and
crazy whatever though it's just a
sideshow it'll go away it doesn't
actually pose a threat but it does okay
in every revolution that's ever taken
place every successful insurrection the
establishment has looked at the first
stages event and said oh that's silly
that'll be put down it's no big deal we
could easily put down these in sections
except we are being told to have no
faith in the police department that the
police shouldn't be able to do anything
and not use any force we are being told
that the so called peaceful protesters
also known as riders also known as in
some ways political terrorists defended
by Chris Cuomo and CNN have the right
idea the right premises they're in the
right well being told all of these
things that's how you get a little crazy
violent event turning into an Tifa
anarchists taking over a whole region
okay they're not even just attacking the
present that is happening
they're attacking the past so in
Richmond last night a statue of
Christopher Columbus was ripped down and
thrown in a lake I think this should be
the final straw to show you this is not
about black lives mattering okay this is
about a radical dishonest organization
called black lives matter that has
nothing to do with black lives mattering
what does Christopher Columbus have to
do with black lives matter Christopher
Columbus whatever ills you want to throw
on this guy whatever evils you want to
accuse him of real or imagined he didn't
have anything to do with black people he
came over from well first Italy then he
went to Portugal then he went to Spain
then he sailed over to the new world any
things that you want to accuse him of
doing terrible awful things he did
against the Native Americans not it's
not like he was the chief of colonialism
in Africa or something and yet he is
being attacked here as well because this
is not about black lives mattering this
is about an attack on the fundamental
traditions and institutions of the West
Halloween at the left goes in and
invades these institutions pretends that
it's not controlling them Hallows them
out from within Christopher Columbus
founded the New World in many ways is
the forefather of our modern
civilization so they've got to attack
him
they've got if you want to have a
radical progressive vision then you've
got to radically attack the past you've
got to leave it so there's nothing left
to conserve so all you can do is move
into that wonderful utopian future and
that's what they're doing there expect
more attacks not just on robert e lee
not just on Christopher Columbus on
George Washington and Thomas Jefferson
you're already beginning to see it and
another thing you're seeing is people
afraid to fly the American flag in their
home four homes in the neighborhood Sun
Garden neighborhood of Citrus Heights
California were targeted early Saturday
morning because they were flying the
American flag and they were targeted by
these peaceful protesters who are
actually just rioters who hate this
country
and they were they were targeted for
supporting the symbol of our country I
got to tell you something when the riots
were moving through my neighborhood in
LA I fly an American flag in the back of
my car I just across the back windshield
I've got an American
like lying down you know on the top of
the seat I had this thought I said gosh
I'm gonna leave the car there the
torching cars all over the place should
I take the flag inside should I put it
in trunk or something I said no I'm not
gonna do that if we've gotten to a point
in this country where I've got to hide
the American flag in a nice neighborhood
in California then the country's lost
let them bash my windshield I'm not
going to do that oh I'll go get my
windshield fixed with dignity rather
than be ashamed of my country or
something like that it would make me no
better than the cowards who are kowtow
into this radical movement but it's a
thought and that's the point of all of
this it's the point of political
correctness that's the point of the
leftist social movements is to make you
think twice make you second-guess mmm
just to be safe maybe I shouldn't fly
this flag just to be safe maybe I
shouldn't say that Christopher Columbus
was a good guy just to be certain uh
I'll just yeah it's just easier for me
to kowtow to these radical leftist
bullies okay and that's how they win
because even if they don't get it right
off the top even if they don't get all
of their aims right off the top that's
how they win their guidelines that were
released by West Hollywood's guidelines
for white people this was this was
pushed by government officials I don't
know who wrote it but it was at least
promoted by government officials it
guidelines for white people showing up
at black LED and people of color led
protests first this is a black issue the
call needs to be black lives matter not
all lives matters so right off the top
they say white people you don't matter
you're you're bad
only black lives matter not you not
other people just you just black lives
sometimes the best way to ensure that
all lives matter is to give black people
room to own a space meaning meaning hey
let's push for segregation that's the
that's fairly progressive now I didn't
think that was progressive but it is
protest from our position for example
don't join in chants that say whose
streets our streets
I kid you not these streets are not our
streets white people in West Hollywood
by the way a very very white
neighborhood are not allowed to say
these are our streets white people have
no ownership or citizenship at all
over any streets and they are only run
by black people according to the silly
document being promoted I don't know
about what about Hispanic people do they
not they don't have money or ownership
of the streets either no call in and
collect white folks who are causing harm
rain in those fellow white people do not
start chants do not grab the microphone
do not speak shut up on the basis of
your race I mean this is disgusting
stuff the way you know it's disgusting
is even the modern culture we call it
disgusting if you just replaced the word
white with black and black with white
and they'd say don't this is a white
issue it's gotta be white lives matter
not all lives matter give white people
room to own a space don't don't allow
black people to chant whose streets our
streets they're not your stir I mean
this is stuff we would say it's
disgusting if it were flipped and yet
this is the kind of stuff being pushed
by not just influential nonprofits but
government leaders too who really owns
these institutions whose streets are
they really I don't think it's a racial
question at all I think it's an
ideological question and the streets are
liberal leftist progressive radical all
those sorts of things you've got I think
this is a point that we've got to show
and getting back to who owns the
institutions look that the right owns
talk radio right their left is tried to
get into talk radio they're no good at
the right does own it but this creates a
problem because we can we can talk about
this kind of hypocrisy we can talk about
this kind of radicalism this awful stuff
until we're blue in the face but so long
as the only institution that the right
owns is talking then all we can do is
talk you've heard some calls in recent
days they say oh gosh enough with the
talking guys do something we'd like to
do something but we don't have any
institutional power we've allowed the
left to dominate all of that
institutional power and you can't just
talk your way back into that not
overnight not right away but we need
that power we need to be able to do it
something because well we talk and we
talk ourselves hoarse the left is still
running those institutions ironically
the very institutions that they pretend
are being run by the awful oppressive
terrible no-good dirty-rotten
conservatives speaking of institutions
that have been manipulated even public
health is this way you remember
yesterday we talked about how the
the World Health Organization is now
saying that asymptomatic people can
barely spread the virus even after they
had all said that asymptomatic people do
spread the virus here they keep changing
their minds masks are bad masks are good
the virus is spread on surfaces the
virus is not spread on services so now
the w-h-o is flipped again even in just
24 hours
they're now walking back their claim
that asymptomatic transmission is very
rare
based on what couldn't possibly tell you
I have absolutely no idea that's the
first one second one remember we were
told the virus had started in January
didn't start before January don't say it
started before January
come on China's telling the truth WHS
telling the truth then we found out it
was December then we found out it was
November then we found out it might have
been as early as October now we've got a
a non peer-reviewed yet Harvard Medical
School study showing that coronavirus
may have appeared in Wuhan as early as
late August of last year late August so
that one totally changed again and then
and then this is the ps/2 resistance be
riots the peaceful riots that had been
going on for the last week or two forced
the closure of 70 coronavirus testing
sites at least if they just had to shut
down because there was chaos going
around we were told by the left by the
public health institutions that the most
important thing is testing everyone's
got to get tested why I couldn't
possibly tell you but they all got to
get tested their Trump's not testing
enough Trump's killing people because
they're not testing enough and then the
protesters come through for left-wing
causes and the riders and the arsonists
and looters and all of a sudden the
testing doesn't matter at all doesn't
matter at all they changed their mind
they have no regard for the truth here
they only have regard for the ideology
that they're pushing which by the way is
very different from the truth before we
get out of here I've got to get to the
dumbest article on the Internet today
this one goes to Susan Rice former
national security adviser for Barack
Obama and well-known liar about the
Benghazi attack Susan Rice in the New
York Times which still exists they
almost fell apart because that dirty
rotten Tom cotton Republican senator
published an op-ed a few days
and that truly toward the newspaper part
almost destroyed it but there's no back
contributing opinion piece from Susan
Rice called Washington DC deserves
statehood this place does not deserve
statehood I am in Washington DC right
now
the whole purpose of Washington DC the
District of Columbia is that it should
not be a state the whole reason it was
created is so that the federal
government is not owned by a single
state we need a place for the federal
government federal government's
different than state governments federal
government needs its own space that is
different from state government that's
how the balance of power works if you
give DC a state you've completely upset
that they say Washington is the only
National Capital in the Democratic world
whose citizens lack equal voting rights
yeah right people aren't supposed to
live in DC it supposed to be a federal
district people can live at in Virginia
where they can live in Maryland they can
move if you choose to live in DC that's
going to come with certain costs because
DC is not a state by the way since when
do we follow the rest of the Democratic
world the rest of the Democratic world
follows us we're the leaders in it we
lack any senators or voting
representative in the House of
Representatives yes that that's true
by design the real reasons for
opposition are racism and political
interest she writes nope
just it's just that design that's what
that's the real reason is federalism why
does this injustice persist into the
21st century because it was set up for a
reason when it was set up before the
21st century and those reasons haven't
gone away over time okay now really
before we go there is there's one thing
I've got to get to I got an email
yesterday from factcheck.org asking me
if I had spread fake news seriously
because you know we have our thumbnails
every day on YouTube and there's kind of
crazy designs we have an artist who
draws them up every single day and
they're always really wild one of them
recently apparently went around the
internet is fake news and it was an
image of a ridiculously defaced Abraham
Lincoln Memorial and it's like part of
his head was chopped off and there was
spray paint I didn't think it looked
real but apparently some people sent it
around and said this is being two-faced
this is fake new so get this email from
factcheck.org which
left-leaning an institution like so many
institutions said were you spreading
fake news are you guys responsible for
this and yes of course our artists drew
up this thumbnail as they draw up
thumbnails every single day so just to
give you a little bit of context though
I want to go through a few of the other
thumbnails we've drawn up and just sways
your fears and let you know that those
are not real either so what else do we
have in recent days we've got we've got
the Lincoln one we've got the Statue of
Liberty kneeling on top of a bunch of
protesters taking a knee so I want you
to know that actually the copper statue
given to us hundreds of years ago by
France did not suddenly come to life and
does not now have bendable knees and
things like that that is an artistic
fictional image what else drea we've got
president Trump as Hercules with a
ripped ripped Greek god body wrestling a
bull by the horns with the face of the
Twitter logo that didn't really happen
okay that's not really Donald Trump and
and the Twitter logo is not a bull then
we've got to Karen's
there Karen's with the Karen haircut you
know and a little dog and a mask
standing staring at you that's not a
photograph that was drawn up by an
artist we've got dr. foul Qi shaking
hands with Satan himself you can see his
pulsating red devil hands there
dr. foul Qi at least to my knowledge has
never literally shaken hands with the
devil I've metaphorically I don't know I
can't speak to that but literally has
not shaken hands with the devil
president Trump dancing around as money
falls from the sky this very possibly
did literally happen but I am telling
you that that image at least was drawn
by one of our artists oh yeah this one's
my favorite a president Trump dancing at
a beach shirtless I we ought to talk to
my artist there's a lot of shirtless
Trump in in these images maybe there's
some Freudian thing I don't know
shirtless ripped pecs you know six pack
abs in a bathing suit dancing in front
of the protesters at the beach who are
saying stay inside and wash your hands
this is not Donald Trump's body everyone
knows that is my body that we
photoshoped president Trump's head on
too so don't confuse that with fake news
anything else
yes Bernie Sanders wearing a fur coat
holding up a skull like Hamlet with a
hammer and sickle emblazoned on the
skull that is not the skull of Karl Marx
or Vladimir Lenin Bernie Sanders is not
the Prince of Denmark though I often
hear him talk about how Denmark as a
socialist country that also it's not a
socialist country and Bernie Sanders is
not Hamlet
this one could be real and I think a lot
of people want it to be real but it's
not real
Donald Trump in a WWE ring body-slamming
a very sad-looking
Mitt Romney that did not happen in the
physical world
it did happen politically symbolically
metaphorically but it did not happen in
the physical world and so that is not a
photograph I hope this clears up fake
news I don't want to be accused of
spreading any more fake news by
factcheck.org so keep that in mind when
you talk about the photos of dr. fancy
shaking hands with the devil or
president Trump literally body slamming
Mitt Romney those are artistic creations
I hope you've enjoyed the thumbnails and
I hope that we haven't confused anybody
any further could you have that
questions invert Amara in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there